[موسيقى]
كنت أطلب منه صورة بعد خروجه
من المحكمة ، لقد قال للتو إنني أحب
حذائك وقال إنه حذاء رياضي لطيف ،
وقلت للتو إنني أستطيع أن أصطحبك إلى
هناك لأنني كنت أقلب الأحذية هنا
و  هناك ، وتعرفت ببطء ولكن بثبات
على زوجين ، وعرفت أنني
أستطيع أن أحصل عليه من الأزواج التي كنت
أرتديها ، كان مجرد
إنستغرام الشخصي الذي أرسله لي ، وقدم
طلبًا لأعتقد أنه كان
ثلاثة أو أربعة أزواج من
مدربو [ __ ] البياض النادرون حقًا وذهبت إلى
منزله حيث كان يقيم قبل
بطولة ويمبلدون ، لقد فاز بالفعل ببطولة ويمبلدون
الزوجي في ذلك العام وأم نعم لقد قمت
بتسليم الحذاء الذي كان سعيدًا
جدًا وذلك عندما بدأت المكون الإضافي على
Instagram لأنك  أراد أن
يصرخني على الإنستغرام
[موسيقى
] وكان سعيدًا جدًا
وكان هذا حقًا أنت تعرف بشكل أساسي
ما احتاجه
لبدء العمل ولتحقيق تقدم حقيقي في
عالم كرة القدم على الأقل لأنه من
ريس حصلت على جو و  بيكايو و اميل و
كل هؤلاء الأطفال الصغار في ذلك الوقت الذين
كانوا يلعبون الفريق الأول في الأكاديمية من
المحتمل أن ينطلقوا في
مباريات الكأس أو يتم إرسالهم على سبيل الإعارة ليصبحوا
الآن النجوم كما هم اليوم
[الموسيقى]